welcome back to another segment of
what's the inel where our Muslim friends
tell us that the gospel that we have is
not the actual gospel but a corrupted
version so this means that the Muslim
can tell us what the angil is let's get
to it welcome off men welcome back to
the stage so tell us what is the inel
then since you say ours is corrupt I'm
I'm talking based on what I've been
taught okay I've never touched the Bible
I've never ever get the Bible so just be
clear you've never read the gospel
you've never touched it you never seen
it so then it wouldn't be right for you
to say that it's corrupted right it
wouldn't be right for you to say that
right no because i' like
I've a Muslim and uh I follow the
religion and everything and I I just
found out about the scientific facts in
the Quran and everything like that so
like I just asked myself how can a man
1400 years ago who was reported to
cannot even write and read how can he
like make that up yeah he heard a lot of
things a lot of traditions a lot of
stories he heard a lot of things
secondly though let's bring this to you
if there were things that were
inaccurate scientifically in the Quran
would that prove that the Quran is false
no okay so if scientific inaccuracies
don't prove that the Quran is false then
scientific accuracy
don't prove the Quran is true so it's
irrelevant whether he got something
change by time change by time okay so if
science changes by time then this is
irrel this is irrelevant bringing this
up doesn't help prove Muhammad's
prophethood because science is flimsy
and you know it doesn't prove or
disprove anything so I'm just saying
someone who cannot all right cannot make
that up see there again so it sounds
like you're appealing to scientific
accuracy shows that he actually has
Knowledge from God right yes so then
that would mean that scientific
inaccuracies means that he doesn't have
Knowledge from God right yes but you
don't know those scientific inaccuracy
maybe in the future they will become
like they will be approved by since like
I saw something like they said that what
the Quran of the Gap it's called the
Quran of the gaps argument you know the
Quran says something
and science disagrees with it but maybe
later on science would uh you know
science please let me finish line up I
saw something like scient scientists
back then they didn't discover that uh
the the sun rolve around the around an
orbit but recently they discover it and
it is said in the Quran so again um
Muhammad also says in the Quran that the
sun sets in muddy spring so does that
mean that Muhammad is false because
obviously according to science the sun
does not set in muddy spring no Muhammad
cannot be false but he says that it's
set
in God said it he didn't say okay so
Allah said that Muhammad I'm sorry Allah
said that the sun sets in a muddy spring
so that means that Allah is saying
something false no but I I told you
earlier that maybe it's it's not Quran
that is wrong like it's not even maybe
it's science that so maybe later on in
the future I got you so maybe later on
in the future science is going
toover the sun in a muddy spring
yes
one
[Music]
meh but
I I like but I I
continue yeah God I have one question
before I go what's your question why
should I accept Christianity because
your Quran tells you to yes speak your
Quran tells you to where in chapter five
verse 47 it says this let the people of
the Gospel judge by what Allah has
revealed in it whoever does not judge by
what Allah has revealed they are of the
wrongdoers so the Quran says for us to
judge by the gospel so you need to
believe in it can you please show me see
5:47 let the people of the Gospel judge
by what Allah has revealed therein in
the gospel and whoever does not judge by
what Allah has revealed such are the
disobedient rebellious so you need to
believe the gospel and once you believe
the gospel you'll see that Jesus is the
son of God who died for your sins and
rose again on the third day and that
Islam is false but the reason I will not
believe like in that directly is because
uh you have to look at the the books and
that will give you the clear
understanding of the ver well the Quran
says that the Quran itself gives me the
clear understanding of the verse the
Quran says that it's the Quran says it's
detailed explanation about everything I
don't need to T can you speak Arabic can
you I can speak Arabic read the Quran
you said you can't speak Arabic but you
could read the Quran yes okay so we're
both we're both non-arabic speakers um
but the position we're in here is that
the Quran says that it itself explains
itself it says that it is the best
Hadith it's the best explanation and
that it's detailed explanation of
everything you said yes so good so I
don't need to go outside the Quran good
so I don't need to go outside the Quran
on when I'm reading the Quran I don't
need to go outside of it to get the
explanation it's right here and what's
clear is that the gospel is what you're
supposed to believe in and what I as a
Christian am supposed to judge by yes
but there what we call
which is explanation of the Quran using
the Quran which is exactly what you just
said and you like you are not a scholar
of the Quran I believe yes I am the
English one though but it seems like you
don't understand the Quran no you just
disagree with me you just disagree you
because like I go to the mo and there is
that we do and all these are imams that
have studied for years and all like yeah
so this is what I would this is what I
would challenge Amit I would love if you
were to bring any of your shakes or any
of your imams to come on the live stream
and I talk to them and I will show you
that they don't know anything and that
they lie about what the Quran says I can
show you that yes but they can't yes
most of them cannot speak English so
what what what language do they speak
now I'm nigeran I speak okay I got some
Nigerian Brothers I can translate yes
I'll will talk to one of my
nice bring them but see here's the point
though so you see what the Quran says
right it says let the people of the
Gospel judge by the goel I believe the
Quran but I don't believe in you yeah
don't hey don't believe in me don't
believe in me at all just believe what
the that's why I'm saying I go to every
single day in the mosque and all this
there are there are Scholars who have
studed for years and they use book they
don't directly use the translation of
the Quran you get what I'm saying imag I
I hear what you're saying so who do you
think is more you know in a better
position one who uses the Quran directly
or one who's using stuff outside of the
Quran no the the they don't use stuff
outside the Quran that's why I told you
like it
isran explanation of the Quran using the
Quran but inside do you need an
explanation for this let the people of
the Gospel judge by what Allah has
revealed in it is that clear to you yes
because who are the people of the Gospel
the Christians man look look look if we
go to the previous verse it says and in
their footsteps we sent Jesus Son of
Mary confirming the Torah that had came
before him and we gave him the gospel in
which was guidance and light and
confirmation of the Torah that had come
before it a guidance and an admonition
for mankind or I'm sorry for the pious
right and then in next verse let the
people of the Gospel judge by what Allah
has revealed in it whoever does not
judge by it they're the wrongdoers yes
wait wait wait who and whosoever does
not judge by what Allah has revealed
them to them what is that in then such
people are such people are fing
rebellious but Allah has revealed the
Quran so we we should we should use what
the Quran has said and Allah revealed
the gospel right yes but so the so the
people of the Gospel are supposed to use
use the gospel right yes right I'm the
people of the Gospel so I have to use
the gospel and when I use the gospel
when I use the gospel it shows me that
the Quran is false yes but what I'm
saying is that this Gospel of today is
corrupted what
and
now you have just hit our favorite
section of the live stream my friend
welcome back to another segment of
what's the inil where our Muslim friends
tell us that the gospel that we have is
not the actual gospel but a corrupted
version so this means that the Muslim
can tell us what the angel is let's get
to it welcome ahed welcome back to the
stage so you said goel is corrupted so
tell us what is the Angel then since you
say ours is corrupted I'm I'm talking
based on what I've been taught right
I've never touched the Bible I've never
ever read the Bible
so just be clear you've never read the
gospel you've never touched it never
seen it but you've just heard that it's
corrupted is that correct no but but
because I don't need it to do my
religion that's why say that again I
don't need it to practice My Religion
you don't need it to practice your
religion but yes according to the Quran
you do and according to your five
pillars you cannot be a Muslim and
reject Allah's scriptures right you have
to believe in them right I believe in
them but I don't need them to practice
My Religion but you do though you do
need them to practice your religion or
else you're not a real Muslim if you
reject them see here's the thing Jesus
wait wait wait good logic I don't reject
them well yeah you you said it's
corrupted I believe in them but I've
never read them because I don't need
them to practice my religion I believe
so let's let me get this straight so a
let's let's be fair to the situation
here then so you've never read the
gospel you've never touched it you never
seen it so then it wouldn't be right for
you to say that it's corrupted right it
wouldn't be right for you to say that
right no because I've seen like I've I
saw a video where you were in it with SH
and he was clearly
showing something from the MAA Bible or
something like that and he was showing
like it is saying that it was an error
in it no what they said was a textual
variant you're saying that textual
variance means that that there's a that
there's a problem with the book If
there's textual variance but I clearly
saw the video in theid clearly saw the
video then you clearly saw my response
is there problems with textual variance
do you even know what a texal variant is
what is that so A textual variant is
when certain when manuscripts right you
have the writings of the manuscripts the
reading of a manuscript and another
manuscript of the same kind will defer
may have a little difference than the
other manuscript so there might be a
slight difference like a number
difference or word difference maybe a
word might be copied multiple times on
you know stuff like that so text that's
what a text variant is so in like most
of our Old Testament text it says his
age is 22 maatic test it it says his age
was 42 so we can see that the Matic text
is wrong when we compare it to the
others other manuscripts it's just a
textual variant right so that's what
that is you have you have this in your
Quran you have textual variant in your
Quran where all over the place can you
give me an example okay I'll give you an
example then you can go ask your shakes
about it okay all right bet all right so
if you go to chapter 37:12 and you can
go ask your shakes about this goodness
we couldn't even do what is the in yeld
with you because you just admitted he's
like I never read nothing I I just heard
we couldn't even do that that's my
favorite segment but that was cut short
when you go to chapter
37:12 we see here it says but you want
while they mock talk Allah's talking to
Muhammad but you wonder while they mock
now the word we're going to be looking
at is this word right here it's a a
which means you wonder the T at the end
of a a it's you wonder the the speaker
is talking to someone else okay where is
the translation I can pull up the
translation on a in a second I'll show
you matter of fact here here here's the
translation that's not what I clicked
here you see nay you wondered while they
mocked see it the word here the same
word aepta all right okay so now going
back so that's the H Quran that's the
one that's most famous the one that most
most Muslims use when we scroll down
going to scroll down to the Quran or the
Hamza Quran and I like this site because
it has the color codes that shows you
the difference it's two the first one is
a this one is a to Allah said say I
wondered while they mo so the first one
is you wondered while they mo this one
is where is this one what where is it
translation translation of this one it's
right here right here rather I am amazed
and they mock so you see how it changes
from you to I yes but uh what I know
this is like this is right say that
again this
is different ntion no this is the same
verse the same Quran same verse and the
other one is
yeah okay what I know about this is they
are basically all the same it's just
different dialects that's what I know
about it and that's wrong because it's
not different dialects these are
different words well I have my no
worries but you see how there's textual
variance even in your Quran I can show
you many of them but this is just one
example I don't want to flood you with
too much just check this one out take
this to your shakes and they're going to
lie to you and tell you yeah these are
just different dialects no dialect is
how people speak right how they
pronounce words right but the meaning
won't change the meaning won't change
here it's a different word with a
different meaning so it's not about
dialect these are different words that
change the meaning of the text one has
Muhammad who's the one who wonders the
other one has Allah who's the one who's
wondering while at while they mock so
that mean the Quran is false right yeah
by your standards okay but you just you
just said to me earlier that even the
Bible which you believe in uh has this
what do you call it texture variance
text variant now this wasn't my standard
of Truth this was yours you said that I
clearly saw that the Bible was corrupted
whenman was bringing up right these
textual variants so yeah I was show and
in that same conversation withman if you
watched well actually you probably
watched on his channel he actually cut
off when we got into this discussion
because I brought this up to him I
brought this up to Usman and he had no
answer for I watch I watch both and
actually what happened is but you also
did the cut I didn't cut anything why
are you lying why are you lying now see
now this this is why I lose respect for
people when you lie why you lying I
watch most of your videos you used to
clip it yeah where where did I clip the
shikan conversation why are you sitting
here in front of 2,000 people lying I'm
not lying yeah you are lying you said
that I clipped that conversation why are
you lying no I didn't lie I I watch most
of your videos on your channel then I I
I'll repeat what you said you said that
I also clipped the conversation that I
had with shik Usman that day that's what
you said why are you lying as if we
can't pull it up and see the whole
conversation is there why are you lying
so but you said that sh Usman C CLI the
you said he cut out the part where I
brought this up he cut it out why why do
you think he did that why do you think
he did that why you think he cut it out
I will go watch the video and so when
you go and you research this this is all
I'm going to encourage you to do do not
come out don't be gullible don't be
stupid don't be dumb do not be easy to
manipulate okay don't be naive use your
critical thinking skills and when they
lie to you pick up on it because they're
going to lie to you I'm telling you
right now they're going to lie you
they're going to tell you oh this is
just different K and oh you know just
different dialects and Muhammad said
that the that the Quran was revealed in
seven different dialects that's this is
not that this are these are different
words that that have different meaning
so has nothing to do with dialect
dialect doesn't change the meaning you
understand what I'm saying okay I I will
go and do my research I I will try as
much as possible to do to be honest and
I I s
inah uh it nice speaking to you got all
right take care